is the holiday season and we're all
shopping a little bit online it has
exploded this year and it's becoming
more essential for us to outsmart those
package thieves that might be watching
your doorstep hard to do a recent
national study says that 210 million
packages just disappeared from porches
in the last 12 months
people of course are shopping online a
bit more and choosing delivery options
to their front door a little bit more
than ever hector meghan joining us live
hector you found out too if these people
get caught they can face some stiff
penalties
that is true and we're also learning
these thefts are going up according to
security website safe flies package
thefts went up 36 percent from 2020 and
these crimes often go unreported to
police they happen year round even if
you have security measures in place that
recent study by safe flights also
revealed more than 53 percent reported
having multiple packages stolen in the
last 12 months three out of four have
fallen victim at some point in their
life also the package these the packages
thieves target most are in this order
first amazon
followed by fedex packages us postal
service and ups one local home and
business security tech company says
sometimes it's not only the package
thieves who you need to worry about
one of the companies that is a delivery
company one of their drivers picked the
bike up put it in his truck and drove
off
so
you never know you never know and that's
why it's it's always good to have the
cameras
there are other ways you can protect
yourself you can sign up for tracking
alerts so you know the second your
precious items arrive have your items
shipped to work a locker or choose
in-store pickup and we also talked with
metro police about the penalties for
example if you're caught stealing
something small like this mac makeup
that's considered a misdemeanor but if
the item is worth twelve hundred dollars
or more like this mic like this macbook
air that's considered a felony and that
could land you in state prison reporting
live hector mejia live local now